I would have to say that this is
probably the one of the roughest seasons
I've seen it's been really tough because
it's been not only not a lot of snow but
really warm temperatures currently we
have probably about 15 percent of our
maybe 20% of our trails so we're
constantly trying to get more things
open my job here in title is overseeing
the snow making we have about 38 snow
makers 20 groomers and 12 park staff we
definitely have one of the biggest
stomach assisters on the west coast so
we're able to convert a lot of water
into the machine mate snow my typical
day is I head up on the mountain right
away I pretty much will ski every run of
the mountain I'm kind of looking around
seeing how the grooming is if we made
snow how they're still making turned out
that's a good snow making in there and
normally at this time you're all these
stumps rocks everything's covered up
yeah we need to try to get a snow gun in
here tonight kind of cover up
most of snowmaking happens you know in
the middle of the night but we will make
snow 24 hours a day if it's cold
here we have our our fleet of air water
gonna these the different guys that will
drag around the mountain to set up
people think that we can make snow of
the whole mountain at one time but we
can't we could we only have so much
capacity it's just looking everywhere
and seeing where we need the snow the
most
how is slogan really works is you have a
hose that runs to near hydrant and also
hose it runs to the water hydrant what
happens they both go to the gun and the
water comes in the front of the gun the
air comes behind it and ejects the water
out into the atmosphere and if it's cold
enough that little Christa will freeze
as it falls to the ground
so if you look at the screen here this
will show the whole mountain so it shows
all the runs on it and it shows where
our four different pump houses are
located around the mountain we fire
water from the utility districts we're a
consumer that just buys water like like
everybody who owns a home does you know
we know there's a drought going on a
Californian stuff but we're allowed to
take as much water as the utility
districts will provide for us we're not
gonna buy any more snow making between
now and the weekend on Canyon but you
know the top part especially is really
thin if we can make it work we'd open it
and then hopefully it's gonna snow this
weekend oh he'll forget after that yeah
definitely Grameen crew
and getting ready to start my night up
here
we just got our list from Barrett down
below priority tonight is just to get
out and cover up some thin spots some
rocks dirt that are showing up
the snow gun will just blow their days
on days and accumulate what we call a
whale a whale is essentially just a
giant pile of snow they'll blow one
whale there one whale here we can
connect them together so we're really
the ones pushing all the snow around and
putting it where it needs to go out of
the depth that it needs to be at
you know I love about this job as I love
the challenge you can see how much more
snow we need for this to be open but
this is really really good it is a
little bit stressful and I do have some
sleepless nights early in the season but
I learned to control that and not worry
about what Mother Nature deals us
no I'm really proud of what we be able
to do with the weather that we've been
dealt with this year because to tell you
the truth if it wasn't for snow making
we would not be open yet
you